whatever you do you want to be excited
about it you want to have the kind of
excitement that is so contagious that
people want to be around you because
whatever you're doing whatever you talk
to people about this particular idea
that you have they're looking at you and
they want to know do you believe and are
you the kind of person they want to be
in business with and if you're not
positive if you're not fired up about it
how can you expect anybody else to be
fired up about your idea am I right
there are a lot of people who say but I
tried once or twice and it didn't work
out and so they used that as an excuse
not to ever come out again at first you
don't succeed you're running about
average if you have come out here with
an idea and it didn't work out two or
three times well that's all right you're
running about average many people die at
age 21. don't get buried until they're
65. they're walking dead I was giving a
speech at this high school and a lady
came after school she said Mr Brown I
want to talk to you about my son I said
what is it she said he's not motivated
Les Brown is about to unlock the secrets
to Financial Freedom and success in this
incredible video through the meantime
series we get to learn from people
who've achieved great things in their
lives and today's Mentor is none other
than Les Brown himself in his
full-length video Les shares his wisdom
on motivation and achieving our goals he
reminds us that winners and losers exist
but there are people who simply haven't
discovered how to win yet they just need
a little guidance coaching and support
to tap into their unlimited potential
and unlock the key to a better future
less encourages us to think about our
own goals and dreams no matter how big
or small they may seem he reminds us
that anything is possible if we believe
in ourselves and maintain a level of
Integrity to keep pushing folk we should
operate out of our imagination not our
memory and believe that we can achieve
anything we set our minds to less gives
us real life examples of people who've
broken barriers and achieved what was
once thought impossible he inspires us
to know that if others can do it so can
we if you're looking for a boost of
motivation and inspiration to chase your
dreams and unlock Financial Freedom then
this video is a must watch get ready to
be empowered and motivated by the
amazing Les Brown
enjoy
we go through life really blocking
ourselves constantly and fears one of
the the greatest instruments that we
could use to stifle our true potential
when you begin to to look at your life
you can decide to to use fear as a
blocker or you can decide to use it as
building blocks that you decide hey look
here I'm going to move in this direction
I'm not going to allow anything to stop
me from doing what I want to do see when
you begin to understand and acknowledge
your fear
and you go forth anyhow
you go forth in a spirit
and a knowing
that there's a way that you can begin to
handle this there's a way
out here somewhere there's a solution
what it is that you're seeking that you
have the capacity to whatever comes up
to handle it to face it and rather than
feeling powerless
you begin to feel powerful
see when all of the major downsizings
that are taking place around this
country there are a lot of people who
are biting their fingers in fear
that they might lose their jobs
but there are few people who have
decided within themselves I'm going to
make it some people aren't waiting to be
cut
some people are moving on their own
because they feel within themselves
I've got what it takes to make it
They're Not Afraid about tomorrow
because of how they see themselves
because of what they feel that they
deserve because of what they feel that
they can create for themselves because
these people have decided as they look
at the future as they look at themselves
there's a way where there's a will
there's a way for me to begin to create
a way out of no way
and when you have that kind of
Consciousness when you have that kind of
spirit nothing can stop you
nothing
what would your life be like
as you look toward the future if you
decided I'm not going to allow my fears
to stop me
what would your life be like
what would your future be like if you
decided to to want that which you desire
so strongly
that It prepares you past your fears
that you experience the fear as the one
book says Feel the fear and do it anyway
what would your life be like
and I'm saying to you
that all of us who have been entombed by
fear
have the capacity to resurrect ourselves
and to resurrect our dreams all of us
have a capacity today
thank you
and you have is it easy no
it's not easy
can I do it yes
what's one of the ways to get started
some of us need somebody to hold our
hands
sometimes we need somebody to help us
out be willing to say I don't know be
willing to reach out be willing to get
some assistance
to take you to the next level at what
great athlete you never expect boxes to
make profound statements I think it was
Joe Frazier said this one he says all of
us are like the blind man at some point
in our lives standing on the corner
waiting for somebody to lead us across
to all of us at some point in our lives
need some help need someone to reach out
to us to throw out the lifeline to help
us go across some treacherous Waters
that we couldn't navigate by ourselves
none of us do it by ourselves all of us
at some point of Our Lives we need that
kind of help we need that kind of
assistance because we grow from the
people we have in our lives that can
enrich our lives personally
professionally spiritually and all the
dimensions of Our Lives we don't grow in
a vacuum
so as you look at yourself what are the
fears you have that maybe you need some
help
and strengthening yourself in that area
as you assess your strengths and your
weaknesses as you begin to approve
yourself and your passions and your
dreams and your goals and the things
that you want if you decide to
experience all of your true potential as
you decide to manifest all of your
greatness
as you decide wait a minute what what
else is available to me out here if I
decided to experience the fear of
rejection the fear of no the fear of
failure
the fear of of standing by myself what
else is available of taking a chance a
fear of losing it all what else is
available to me
that will bring some extra meaning and
value
the fear of people not liking me you
know how many people do things they
don't want to do because they want
everybody to like them
everybody's not going to like you
excuse me special announcement
no that's it's just not that kind of
world what but you know a lot of people
who won't take positions on issues who
won't take a stand for things they
believe in who won't speak up for
themselves because they don't want to
make anybody mad
oh it was Bill Cosby he said I don't
know what the secret of success is he
said but here's what I know with the
secret of failure is he said trying to
please everybody
you can't please everybody
but there are people who have the fear
of rocking the boat
so they just go alone in life just go
alone well how do you feel well I don't
really want to say
if you know people like that raise your
hand these people aren't living life
they're not truly experiencing life what
do you really want to do well I don't
like this but I guess I'll go ahead on
and do no all the life is too short for
that too short and unpredictable mosing
through
not trying to disturb anything not
trying to shake anything up not trying
to make any waves
you see there are some people who who
come through the universe in their level
of contribution and the level of energy
they manifest is so small so
inconspicuous that when they go you
won't even know they left
I mean they're people who die on jobs
and and you say Hey where's John oh
John's been dead six miles
you're kidding no is that right yeah
I didn't know why did somebody say well
I guess we didn't miss him but there's
some people because of their personality
because of their contribution because of
their the investment of their time and
their energy and the impact they have
there that when they go everybody will
miss them see when Mother Teresa checks
out everybody will know when Rosa Parks
everybody will know Nelson Mandela
everybody will know why because of their
contribution
see but there's some people because
their contribution is so small
no one will care
some saying before you are boxed and
buried
decide that you're gonna box and bury
your fears
decide that you're going to begin to
live life on a new level seeking out New
Horizons that you're going to find more
love and more joy and more ways to give
more to life God said something I love
this he says everything a man does for
himself
guess what
he takes with him but everything he does
for others he leaves behind
so when you begin to say what is it that
I want to leave
what contribution that I want to begin
to make what difference do I want to
make in life
what is it that I want to do with the
rest of the life that I have left what
what chances I need to take what risk do
I need to begin to embrace what fears do
I need to step on
what areas of my life am I dead right
now what dream you can either Live Your
Dreams or live your fears you have got
to get to a point where you say I'm sick
and tired of living like this there's
got to be more
that's see that's when people go out and
strike out on their dreams that's when
people get out of relationships where
they're dying together rather than
growing together that's where they leave
Johnson where are you going away from
here I don't know also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
a habit
develop the habit of setting standards
and others will be measured by someone
said do not go where the path may lead
but go where there's no path and leave a
trail
all right
it is easy to be negative today
it is easy to have low morale today I
was at a corporation and they're they're
going through downsizing and going to
lay off some 1500 people over the next
few weeks it's very depressing there and
those people that stay there nine times
out of ten they're just going to do just
enough to keep from getting fired
anybody can do that but if you can begin
to harness yourself and say that where I
am I'm going to do the best I can with
what I got because that is an expression
of who I am if you get into the habit of
just being mediocre it will become a
part of your Consciousness if you get in
a habit of giving less than what you
have it within you to give it will begin
to reflect itself in your personality
it will begin to damage you
psychologically
and you don't want to be a part of that
kind of self-destructive Behavior
and so you want to set some high
standards for yourself
the next thing part of what feeds that
hunger you've got to develop a sense of
urgency
Aurelia said stop living your life like
you have a thousand years to live
in life you either here today and you're
gone today
if there's something that you want to do
and you can't do it all at one time do
just a little bit of it I like what
Robert Schuler says he said by the yard
it's hard but inch by inch anything is
Ascension
just a little bit of
a friend of mine Bobby Kerr used to be a
roommate Bobby wanted to go into the
area of public relations he loved
working with the public
young lady who wanted to marry named
Clarice
Bobby was a great procrastinator
pretty soon the job where Bobby worked
they transferred him to another location
he went out to celebrate with the people
on that new job site and Bobby suffered
a massive heart attack and died Bobby
didn't drink and didn't smoke was under
40. and he died ask you a question how
much time do you have left
how much time do you have left
when you start thinking about that we
don't know we don't know Bobby took all
the greatness and all of the talent and
all of his abilities to his grave with
him
one of the things he could have put in
parenthesis under his name he didn't use
all his stuff
and most of most of us do that
most of us don't use the stuff that we
have brought into the universe
and we want to make a conscious
deliberate determined effort to start
living life with a sense of urgency and
using what we've got
using ourselves up
sharing what we brought into the
universe to share because if we don't
nobody else will
stop wasting valuable time
knowing that if we begin to live our
lives as if each day were our last Our
Lives will take all take on a whole new
meaning
and take on a whole new expression
valuing each moment
that we are blessed with
the next thing that begins to nurture
at Hunger honor yourself as your word
when you throw your throw you it out
there and you don't honor it it makes a
statement about you
if you decide
to maintain a sense of Integrity with
yourself
that if I speak it
I'm going to live it
it's who I am
and I'm going to be very cautious and
how I give my word to others and most of
all with the commitments that I make to
myself
because I want my life to reflect my
words
and honoring who I am and what I express
I want you to look at something right
now think of some major goal you want or
maybe it's one you're already working on
and you have experienced a lot of
setbacks a lot of defeats you've
experienced a lot of disappointment
maybe you've already given up and maybe
you just need a little fire a little
encouragement to get back in the game
again here's what I want you to look at
they're winners
and they're losers
and there are people who have not
discovered how to win
and all they need is some coaching
all they need is some help and
assistance just a little support all
they need is some insight or different
strategy of plan of action to make some
adjustments that will open up the key to
a whole new future for them that will
give them access to the unlimited power
that they have within themselves that's
all that they need
so what I want you to do is is think
about
something you want for you
that's real for you
that's important for you that will give
your life some special meaning and Power
and I don't even want you to say I can
do that
I don't want you to assume that see five
years ago when I started out in this
area I would not have been able to make
the mental leap that I would be up to
where I am right now
I don't want you to begin to just psych
yourself out no no I want you to be able
to say something to yourself that will
enable you to maintain a level of
Integrity with yourself that when you
say this even when you face tremendous
setbacks it it will be a benchmark to
keep you in the game to keep you moving
forward and experimenting and
readjusting your strategy and your plan
of action continuously looking for ways
to win so what is that something
when you got an idea you want to move on
you might not have the money you might
not have the education you might not
have the support of the resources you
need what is that something
that can keep us going that will enable
us to act on our grief what's one of
those keys
that will begin to help us to discover
the secrets to our Dream here's what I
want you to repeat after me please with
power and conviction say it's possible
it's all I want you to do when you look
at your dream you say to yourself every
day it's possible
you say that every day to yourself it's
possible
because what does that do see
it begins to change your belief system
see the way in which we operate ladies
and gentlemen
it's a manifestation of what we believe
what's possible for us whatever you've
done up to this point all that it really
is
is a duplication it's a reproduction of
what you believe subconsciously that you
deserve and what's possible for your
life
most people operate out of their
personal history out of their memory
things they have done things have
experienced things have seen things that
they have observed what I'm suggesting
that you operate out of a larger vision
of yourself I want you to see yourself
doing what you want to do experiencing
what you want to experience it having
what you want to have doing what it is
that gives your life some meaning and
value operate out of your imagination
not your memory because whenever you
look at where you want to go I wanted to
warn you you will have some conversation
back here after you go through the data
that you've experienced in life saying
you can't do it
and so what you want to begin to do is
ignore that inner conversation
well most people ladies and gentlemen
when something happens to them what they
do is they begin to believe that that's
the way it is that's the way it's always
been and they can't see the possibility
of it being any different
example
before in April 1954
the common belief the universal belief
because it had been tried again and
again and again and people have failed
the belief was that man was not
physically capable
of breaking the four-minute barrier that
he could not run a mile in less than
four minutes that was the belief on the
planet it had never been done
but here's what happened ladies and
gentlemen
Roger Bannister came along
and he broke the four-minute barrier
now here's What's significant about that
since that time up to this day over 20
000 people have done it including high
school kids
what changed
20 000 people what changed here's what
happened when they got on the track they
knew it had been done
and because they knew it had been done
there was a new belief about this
barrier about this goal that was
unreachable
and those 20 000 people got in a race
believing
knowing in their heart that someone had
done it that it's possible that they
could do it
and I'm saying that if you know anybody
that had some goals Some Dream something
they wanted to do
and they did it denied saying that you
know in your heart that if someone has
done it then you can do it it's possible
and that if someone can make that dream
become a reality that it's it's possible
that you can make your dream become
reality
and so as you begin to look at where you
want to go
beginning to embrace that
it's possible I'm blessed and highly
favored I've got a lot going for me I
got some good stuff in me
and it's possible that I can bring my
greatness out here in the universe
that I can do what I want to do it's
possible I can write my own book I can
have my own business I I can take the
trip and travel around the world it's
possible I can bounce back from
adversity and reinvent my life it's
possible regardless of where I am the
things can get better for me it's
possible but I'm thinking about two men
right here in Chicago who are fairly
successful
similar background
educated they work for a corporation for
many years
and they were among many people that
were laid off two guys who were very
good friends
one when I'm looking for a job for
several weeks along with the other one
and they face disappointment and
rejection again and again and again they
couldn't find any work
which is the story of many people across
this country
one guy stopped
he became discouraged
he stopped going
he stayed home looking at television
became very argumentative and toxic with
his wife
drinking beer getting on the phone
talking to his other negative unemployed
friends
and he just gave up
the other guy kept looking for a job
everywhere he could go every time he
could get an opportunity kept asking
people networking checking the
newspapers every day kept going
everywhere he could trying to find a job
you have too much education you
overqualified you won't be here long
enough he kept going he kept going
he went to a place and said look here I
tell you what if you can't hire me and I
know you can use my talents abilities
and skills I don't want to sit home and
do nothing just just let me do some
volunteer work you don't have to give me
anything all right I just want to work I
want to be busy
God said okay I'm telling you now but
don't don't expect me to give you
anything it's okay this guy came in and
working with the first one there the
last one to leave was the best employee
there
about four weeks later
one of the top managers quit
they were looking for a replacement
guess who they selected
this other guy this guy who was
volunteering his time
he got the job
what was the difference between the two
men
eyesight and mine sight eyesight is
judging on what you see
judging according to appearances
but mindsight is how you interpret what
you see one guy said it's not possible
it's over I'm finished I can't do it I
can't make it
he surrendered I'm faced rejection again
and again I'm not going anymore there
are no jobs out there
but this other God
he felt that in spite of the nose and
rejections in spite of how bad the
economy is in spite of what the
newspapers are saying
that it's possible
that somebody somewhere will give me a
job he just kept going
thinking it was possible
and guess what ladies and gentlemen
that's what we have to do with our
dreams
because things happen to you in life
that you can never ever anticipate and
many times when those things happen you
want to give up
I remember when I was in broadcasting
when I was a disc jockey I became very
controversial not only being a disc
jockey but I felt that radio was
something that you not only entertain
people with but you also Empower them
you educate them
and I got fired how to just leave they
fired me
that was a shock
I said wait a minute
they took my microphone I thought that
was who I was
no no ladies and gentlemen it wasn't
I had to do something else
and I didn't know what else I could do
see here's what I'm looking at what are
the uses for your life right now that
you haven't even reached for yet see I
believe that when you don't have enough
encouragement to act on your dreams or
ideas or you're not enlightened enough
that life will act on you
see life had moved on me and said Les
Brown you have outgrown this it's time
for you to do something else well I
wasn't enlightened about organized some
discharges and got my job back
so they had to find me a gift
by twice
here's what I did I had to think of
something else
until a guy suggested to me he said Les
why don't you run for office
I said
I've never known anything about
how to operate in the political Arena
I've heard encourage people to register
to vote and get out to vote but I don't
know anything about politics he said
neither do the people who run for office
all the time
thank you
so I ran now here's what I'm suggesting
I ran you got to do what you can where
you are with what you have I didn't have
any money
I didn't know anything about the
political process
I didn't even have any support
but here's what the guy told me it's
possible you could win
that's all I had
I was running against an endorsed
candidate
he was an incumbent he had the newspaper
support all of the leadership in the
community
and I was challenging this guy
so I had a saying when I was on radio
stand up for what you believe in because
you can fall for anything
one side of the street I would
be to us hello my name is Les Brown tell
everybody I'm still standing
get on the phone shout Less Problems to
my house today you know
the mouth yeah
yeah still standing see I'm saying just
just keep moving don't start feeling
sorry for yourself don't spend time
blaming and talking about what happened
to you see whatever you talk about
that's what you multiply and expand in
your life experience so don't talk about
stuff unless you wanted to keep on
happening to you all right
so
I got in that kind of option
as I continue to do that
have my children with me we're going
door to door didn't have enough money
eventually we got close to the election
and something happened that really
surprised me guys who I thought were
going to even support me or stay out of
it various powerful Community leaders
they became involved in it and they
endorsed my opponent
I felt devastated now that's going to
happen to you when you're working on
your dream things are going to happen
that's going to catch you on the Blind
Side that was shocking to me they didn't
have to do that all they had to do just
stay out of it
but here they go come up in there
messing with me
personal business will stop you from
living your dream all right
but I didn't deal with that you want to
make your dream come true you got to
stay focused some people rather get even
than get ahead stay focused on where you
want to go
I just kept on doing what I was supposed
to do
and so I was driving to the radio
station my opponent had over twenty
thousand dollars I had less than eight
hundred dollars
if I was in the radio station the guy
said you're going to make a commercial I
said yes he said it better be a good one
because that money can't go pretty far
here
foreign and I sat there in the middle
control room and I was thinking
and here's what happens when you get
still
stuff will start coming something said
call your mama you used to talk about
your mother on the air all the time ask
her to say a few words for you that'll
be a different kind of political Spa
so I called my mama
and I had a a gospel record playing in
the background
and then I had my mother say hello this
is Mrs Mamie Brown when I raised my sons
I raised him to be good children when
they got out of hand I'd beat their
behind and made them go right please
vote for my son he's a good boy
usually in the state representative race
maybe three or four thousand people will
come out to vote in a primary and that
primary race over 27 000 people came out
and voted said I'm voting for Les Brown
because his mama said he's a good boy
I won ladies and gentlemen I won
so you've got to be willing to stay
focused to be creative to be relentless
because things are going to happen to
you when you're working on your dream
when you get on track I remember when I
first got involved in speaking one of
the main things that speakers like to do
is fake to speak to a certain
Association that they have over 10 000
of their sales reps and come to this
convention and I was relentless I kept
saying it's possible it's possible see
what I want to let you know and set you
up for because you said it's possible
don't mean that you're not gonna have
any problems
that Murphy's Law he gonna come and slap
you side the head
in the parking lot
oh you say it's possible okay it's
possible
well I was working I kept saying it's
possible they got other speakers on this
program I can be on that program too I
kept selling myself I got all fired up
and I was calling him every day every
day and the lady finally said Mr Brown I
tell you what we want you to come in and
talk to our sales Executives you got to
kind of fire and guts that they want
that will motivate them and let me tell
you something else we want you to bring
your motivational tapes you're going to
need at least fifty thousand dollars
worth of tapes I said is that right yes
because they want to keep that drive
alive I said all right I call a guy to
duplicate my tapes I said Don how you
doing this is less let me tell you I got
a major speaking engagement I said man
it's a speaker's dream I need over fifty
thousand dollars worth of product he
said Les you don't have that kind of
credit laughs
I said I know but Don I can sell that
just just right after speaking
engagement I'll give you money in four
days he said are you sure less I said
yes but I got a major speaking
engagement and they told me to do it he
said man that's a big order let me talk
with the lady with you I said hold on
just a minute man call Lady back hello
Evelyn how you doing
this bro I got Don on the phone what did
you
just meant yes you do and what else you
suggest less uh people they buy a lot of
tapes your take's a very popular among
them I'm saying bring at least fifty
thousand dollars worth of tapes less
you'll sell everything you got and more
I said did you hear that dog he said yes
I said now if anybody else has to make a
decision are you the final person she
said I'm the final person I will send
you the contract I want you I said you
hear that down he said yes I said oh
yeah of little faith
I said duplicate the text man hunt the
photo
well
he duplicate the tapes
one week came by I'm checking the mail
every day
no contract
I said come on Murphy don't start
nothing man come on
come on man give me a break come on you
know just ain't fair come on man
give you for a break come on I talk to
myself you know
I don't want to call him right now
two weeks passed by Murphy said don't
you think you ought to go
I said okay I call I say hello
this is Les Brown calling how you doing
unless I said fine I said um Evelyn
hasn't sent my contract out yet any
additional information you need so
listen you haven't heard I said no I
said Evelyn died
I said she died
I said
did she say anything about me
when I got home I was so wiped out
and Murphy was in the house waiting on
me
Birdman said is it possible you want to
listen to some of your tapes
thank you
but ladies and gentlemen here's what I
had to do
I had to begin to focus on what was the
solution that this was not the only
place that I'll be able to sell those
products
and as I began to challenge myself and
got some help and support and some other
input I eventually did it took longer
but it was challenging it's hard
changing your life
it was hard when just over three years
ago
in the Penobscot building in Detroit
Michigan
where I was operating my business
and I fell on some hard times
and I was sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said excuse me Mr Brown Can
we see you for a moment and I said yes
and I walked up to the counter and he
gave me an envelope
and he said would you mind reading it
here and I opened the envelope and the
envelope was from management that said
this is an office tower
it's not a hotel
please
do not sleep in your office
and I said excuse me sir I said I just
worked long hours
and creating my business I'm an
entrepreneur
and right now things are bad for me but
they're not going to be this way always
and I just asked for the opportunity to
continue to operate like I'm doing I'm
not trying to make this my home
and it was hard coming through the lobby
and sometimes they would laugh there's a
guy talking about becoming successful
and look at him he's bathing in the
bathroom upstairs on the 21st floor he
sleeps on the floor him and two other
dreamers up there look at him
it was hard ladies and gentlemen coming
to speak to people
and I was facing financial difficulties
in my own life
I was behind on my bills and my dreams
and I'm saying to them you can live your
dream it was hard ladies and gentlemen
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing that I could do it
there were times that I doubted myself I
said God why why is this happening to me
I'm just trying to take care of my
children and my mother I'm not trying to
steal a rock from anybody
why did this have to happen to me
it was very hard
and here's what I want to say to you
for those of you that have experienced
some hardships
don't give up on your dream
no one could have convinced me by
holding on
by continuing to push forward
by continuing to run toward my dream
that one day
I would have my own talk show
it's a long shot ladies and gentlemen
from Liberty City an abandoned building
on a floor
never knowing my mother or father it's a
long shot being here with you today in
this Dome
in Atlanta it's a long shot no College
training labeled educable mentally
but I kept running toward my
dream
don't stop
[Applause]
don't stop running towards your dream
foreign
it's very important
as you hold on to that dream
they're moments when you're going to
doubt yourself
their rough times are going to come but
they have not come to stay they have
come to pass
it's very important for you to know that
don't say I'm having a bad day see I'm
having a character building day
[Applause]
very important for you to believe
that you are the one
to make this happen I remember
this High School teacher Mr Leroy
Washington
at the end of school one June it was
just a few days before we were supposed
to leave
and I just got my report card
and it indicated that I'd fail history
and I fail English
and I would have to go to summer school
and I was feeling Within Myself
that I was a failure that I I'm slow
than most people and getting paperwork
and and I was feeling down on myself and
and very negative
and Mr Washington was giving a speech to
the graduating seniors and I was in 11th
grade
and even though I wasn't supposed to be
in there
I went in there because the speech he
was giving that speech was for me
and as he talked my heart began to beat
fast
tears began to run by my eyes and I was
in the back just listening to him
because he said and he was a very
dramatic man
I still talk to him to this day
he said as graduating seniors of Booker
T Washington High School
I want you to know that you're blessed
and highly favored
and that as you go toward the future
begin to know that you have greatness
within you
and if just one of you here
begin to Envision yourselves as being
blessed and highly favored to reach your
goals if just one of you
capture the essence of what that means
that you have greatness within you and
responsibility to manifest that
greatness
that you can make your parents proud you
can make your school proud you can touch
millions of people's lives and the world
will never be the same again because you
came this way and the students gave him
a rousing standing ovation and as he
left the auditorium I ran down the steps
and I caught him in the parking lot I
said Mr Washington
he said yes I said do you remember me
sir
he said no I said um my name is Leslie
Brown my mother she works in the
cafeteria here I'm one of the twins
Leslie and Wesley I said Miss Washington
but you know you know I got these Big
Dreams you know I like talking to people
I love people I said I want to work with
people and I got this dream of buying my
mom a home
could could I do that Mr Washington
he said it's possible Mr Brown
and as he walked away I called him again
I said Mr Washington
he said what do you want now
I said uh
I'm the one sir
I said I'm the one you you remember me
sir
I miss maybe Brown's boy
I'm the one
[Applause]
foreign
because you are the one
and I remember when PBS first played one
of my specials called you deserve one
Sunday afternoon in Miami Florida
I had some friends call him to tell him
to tune in
and he watched the program he called me
in Detroit and I answered the phone and
I said hello he said may I speak to Les
Brown please I said who's calling
he said you know who this is
I said Oh Mr Washington it's you
he said you were the one weren't you
I said yes sir he said and you were so
crazy I said I know but I'm rich now
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
it's not going to be easy
it was hard laying on the floor of the
Penobscot building looking out of the
window daydreaming saying less can you
do this
can you make this happen
I used to listen to tapes day in and day
out
about see you at the top my my great
friend Zig and and Dennis Whitley and
different other motivational speakers
and Dr Norman Vincent Peale and Dex is
saying don't let nobody steal your dream
I used to ask myself can I do this
and something said Within Me
you're the one
and let me tell you something ladies and
gentlemen
while you're here
and before you go back home to your
respective cities and communities
write down at least five reasons
on why you deserve your dream
and why you won't give up
what's going to make you Unstoppable why
you must be unreasonable because logical
practical thinking says you can't do it
today but if you want to produce
unreasonable results in your life like
living your dream and taking charge of
your destiny you've got to be an
unreasonable person you've got to be an
uncommon person
so write down the reasons of why you're
here
my first major goal was to buy my mother
a home
and let me tell you something ladies and
gentlemen what what will reasons do Les
Nietzsche said if you know the wife for
doing you can endure almost anyhow what
do you mean by that if you know why
you're doing something when the hard
times come and they're going to come
when the disappointments and rejections
come and they're going to come by the
truckloads your reasons will be your rod
and staff to comfort you to pick you up
once again I got a saying on one of my
tapes if life knocks you down try and
land on your back because if you can
look up you can get up let your reasons
get you back up
foreign
I remember when I I bought the home from
my mother and she came
out of the car when I opened the door I
said Mom I think I know these people in
this house that's my first major goal
and then I couldn't conceal it anymore I
said Mom I got this for you
and as she went from room to room
looking at the house and saying thank
you Jesus
thank you Lord no one ever
could have convinced me that this could
have happened to me
and she looked at me she said Leslie
and you cost me so much problems as a
boy you were always into stuff
she said no one could have convinced me
that day when I walked in that house
and this lady was holding you and your
brother
and she said ma'am I want you to promise
me two things
and she'd say what is it
she says one promised me
that you won't separate them she said I
want them raised together I want them to
know each other I got pregnant while my
husband was away in the war and I can't
keep them
promise me
that you won't separate them she said I
promise I won't I've never had children
I promise I won't separate him and she
said promise me
that you'll never tell them about who I
am because if my husband ever found out
he would kill me
she said I promise
and she said that she gave them to us
and and she kind of cried and she was
walking out the door and she looked at
my adopted mother she said remember
don't you separate them
she said I swear to God I want
I won't separate them I'll keep them
together
and she said as I held you all in my
arms I never had any children of my own
I didn't know how I was going to do it
but I knew with the help of God
I will do it
hey ladies and gentlemen
my mother had a dream of having children
and raising us she didn't know how she's
going to do it you're going to be just
like that and some of you are already
there well you don't know how
you're going to make this happen but you
just feel within yourself some way
somehow with the help of God I'm going
to make it happen repeat after me please
no matter how bad it is
or how bad it gets
[Applause]
I'm going to make it
Shake somebody's hand on your right and
left and say you got the right stuff
so yes
it's possible for you to live your dream
it's necessary that you associate with
winners that you worked your system that
you are Relentless that you never give
up
it's you you've got to take personal
responsibility you've got to make it
your personal business to make it happen
and you've got to resolve within
yourself
that I can do this that it's hard but
you've got to say I'm the one
I'm the one to make this happen I'm the
one to become successful in this
business as you work to help other
people to become successful that feeds
your success
but you know it's going to be hard but
find out what will make it worth it for
you
most people are not accumulating wealth
most people are living in poverty most
people are living far below their
potential not because they don't have
the capacity not because they have not
been given Authority and dominion over
everything on the face of the Earth but
most people are living like they're
living because of the fact that they
don't believe they can have any more
than what they now have
in the book called The miseducation of
the Negro got to Cottage woods and said
if you can determine what a man shall
think you'll never have to concern
yourself with what he will do if you can
make a man feel inferior you never have
to compel him to seek an inferior status
for he will seek it himself and if you
can make a man feel justly and Outcast
you never have to order him to go to the
back door he'll go without being told
and if there's no door his very nature
will demand one
that's why scripture reminds us being
not conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
so every day you have to sell yourself
and get out of your mind those old
thoughts that old belief system every
day you've got to sell yourself on that
it's possible
that you got to put a new mind in you
you got to get out of your mind you got
to begin to restructure your thinking
every day you've got to begin to
recondition your mind see many of us go
through life making choices thinking
it's our choices and it's not what do
you mean by that
a reminder of uh the great
Anthropologist Margaret Mead she was in
a restaurant in Europe and a waiter saw
her and said oh how are you I'm so glad
to see you he said there are several
other Americans here tonight and she
said is that right he said yes he's she
said when you served in dessert let me
know and I'll tell you exactly how many
are here
he said that's not possible she said let
me know after you serve dessert when he
served dessert he came back and he told
her she got up she walked around
and she looked and she observed and she
said you have exactly
65 Americans here
he checked the guest list and he was
amazed he said how did you know that
she said because
in Europe when you eat a slice of pie or
cake you eat it from the back toward the
tip
in America when we eat a slice of pie of
cake we eat it from the tip toward the
back how many of you when you eat a
slice of pie cake you eat it from the
tip toward the back raise your hands
please
good now what else is in your mind
what else are you doing unconsciously
that you don't even know I'm going to
say something and I want you to answer
it after it I want you to end it for me
Winston tastes good like what
how many of you don't even smoke Winston
but know it raise your hands please now
that commercial been off the air for 30
years
30 years see let me share something with
you the easiest thing I've ever done was
to earn a million dollars
the most difficult thing I've ever done
was to believe it could happen to me
that was the most difficult part to
believe that given my circumstances if
my birth parents came down this aisle
right now I would not know either one if
my daddy came up here or my mother came
up here given the fact that I was born
in an abandoned building on a floor
being labeled educable mentally
not having any college training I used
to feel all my life
that people who had college degrees were
more intelligent than me I remember
going to see the late Dr Norman Vincent
veal the author of the book The Power of
Positive Thinking and I used to look at
him up on stage and I said I could do
that I would love to talk to people I
love to talk to people and I said I can
do that
but then when I started going back to my
car
my mental conditioning activated itself
and it said Les Brown you can't do that
you don't have a college education Les
Brown you can't do that you don't have
the training you've never worked for a
major corporation you can't do that what
makes you think you can earn 5 10 15 20
000 in an hour you don't earn that now
working for two or three months what
makes you think that you can speak for a
t Procter Gamble McDonald's Corporation
General Electric these are clients I
have now you've never even worked for
them how many have ever thought about
something you wanted to do and you talk
yourself out of it raise your hand if
you know what I'm talking about that
inner conversation is what's going to
haunt you after standing here and saying
I can do all things in Christ who
strengthens me after saying that again
and again we are more than conquerors
that inner conversation will cause you
when you leave here to go back leading a
life of mediocrity leading a life of
unproductivity leading a life of poverty
so I'm going to share with you how to
break out of that
I want to share with you how to reach
your goals I think the Bible's greatest
motivational book ever been written
now I want you to repeat after me please
we got to recondition our minds first
let us say together good things are
supposed to happen to me
yeah write that down I want you to say
that to yourself every day see we live
in a world where we believe that bad
things are supposed to happen to us I
remember the point of my life Bishop
when things are going good for me and I
said this is too good to be true
something is bound to happen guess what
it did thou shall decree a thing that
shall be established unto you and shall
accomplish that we're into it has been
sent watch your words and watch what you
say about yourself about your Affairs be
conscious of that on a daily basis why
because your words are powerful in the
beginning was the word life and death is
in the tongue watch what you say never
say I'm broke say I'm overcoming a cash
flow problem
yeah
claim what you want not what you don't
want
so affirm good things as opposed to
happen to me and begin to believe that
begin to expect that
now
I was talking to my
oldest son
Calvin we're going for a walk
and I said Calvin do you want to be
successful he said yes sir dad
it's okay we kept on walking
then I stopped and I looked him in the
eyes
is my namesake my junior
I said Calvin we're looking at each
other now
do you expect to be successful
given the fact that you are a single
parent of two kids
given the fact that you decided not to
go to college to further your education
given the fact that you're very talented
but you're behind on your dreams and
your bills do expect based upon your
performance based upon what you produce
at this point in time in your life do
you expect to be successful
and Calvin got quiet
because see if you ask most people at
the Manpower conference do you want to
be successful
do you want to live a life of
productivity do you want to live a life
of contribution do you want to be a
better father do you want to have your
own business are there dreams you want
everybody will say yes but see once
shows up in conversation expectation
shows up in Behavior
see I can tell what you expect by what
you do that's why the Bible says judge a
tree by the fruited Bears not the fruit
that it wants
not the fruit that it talks about not
the fruit that it claims
but by what you are doing see what you
do when you leave here when the Music
Stops when the shouting dies down your
behavior
how you conduct yourself writing your
goals down deciding to enroll in school
to get a GED deciding to sit into class
with children young enough to be your
grandchildren decide to find some
product some idea some service that you
can provide so that you can begin to
create some value for yourself so you
can create wealth and let me tell you
something ladies and gentlemen it's very
important that we begin to learn how to
create wealth
I'm not talking about loving money see I
believe the lack of money is the root of
all evil
people are steal for money people are
killed for money
people go to jail for money every time
the unemployment goes up in those areas
where the unemployment is high that's
where you have the highest incidence of
crime and violence whenever the
unemployment goes up one percent in our
community ten thousand children and
women are better
what money makes a difference in your
life I never wanted to be rich all I've
ever wanted to do was to be comfortable
how many of you ever want to be
comfortable raise your hands then I
realized in order to become
[Applause]
an old friend of mine zigzagar would say
people say money won't make you happy
but everybody want to find out for
themselves
Rita Davenport say money ain't important
but it's right up there with oxygen
let me tell you something fellas even if
you
women will find something cute on you
[Applause]
he got earlobe like Denzel hunting
money makes a difference
I used to be so broke when creditors
would call the house my children would
answer the phone and say my daddy say
here
[Applause]
I'm so broke at one time my life I
walked by a bank and tripped the alarm
I tell you poverty sucks you hear me
laughs repeat after me please I'll never
be broke again
[Applause]
let's write that down I affirm that I'll
never
[Applause]
will I ever be broke again
let me tell you what money does
number one
it gives you control over your life
write that down
number two it gives you options
three
it allows you to live a life of
contribution to contribute to things
that you feel strongly about
like this ministry and the work of
project 2000 will be doing the change
the lives of young people Bishop Jake's
vision is that we can have little league
football teams and baseball teams and
basketball teams then we can have little
league dermatologists and cardiologists
and endocrinologists so he's now
establishing an institution project 2000
to give our young people the methods the
techniques to reinvent themselves as we
go into the next millennium and this era
that Peter Drucker calls the era of the
three C's accelerated change
overwhelming complexity and tremendous
competition so here's the first step to
accumulating wealth if you expect to do
it write this down you must be willing
to do the things today others won't do
in order to have the things tomorrow
others won't have
that's why the Book of Life sent the
road to life is straight and narrow and
few there be that find it because fuel
there be that are willing to do the
things today others won't do
in order to have the things tomorrow
others won't have what are the things
that others won't do number one make
discipline a major force in your life
how many of you know if you'd have been
more disciplined you'd be further along
to reach your goals right now
Socrates said the undisciplined life is
an insane life
the road to life is straight and narrow
because few there be that are willing to
discipline themselves
here's something else that most people
won't do make it okay to fail
a lot of people 85 percent of people
allow Their Fear of failure to outweigh
their desire to succeed
repeat after me please anything that's
worth doing
foreign
is worth doing badly
yeah see anything is worth doing is
worth doing right as we have been taught
if you know how to do it but if you
don't know how to do it it's worth doing
badly until you get it right
[Applause]
I bet you and I wasn't there I bet you
that when Bishop TD Jakes first stood up
to preach when he gave his trial sermon
he did not have a command he did not
have the Mastery he did not have the
confidence he did not have the depth he
did not have the capacity to translate
and milk scripture like he did last
night when he first started out
now write this down you don't have to be
great to get started but you have to get
started to be great
the first time I stood up to speak I
stood up and my mind set down
I look at the audience and I panic I had
to introduce a play at school
oh
we about
we're about to start
huh
ran off Mr Washington Mr Brown where are
you going oh Mr Wash and I I can't think
Sarah I I I I I don't know did you
rehearse yes sir I did well what's wrong
why did you say your lies I I don't I
don't know sir I just I got up and I
looked at him and everything left me let
me do it another day please her no go
back out there Mr Bob Mr Washington I'll
mess up please sir don't don't don't
send me I did not I'll mess up Mr Brown
if you run now you will always be
running anything that's worth doing it's
worth doing badly until you get it right
why are you moving right there I gotta
go to the bathroom Sir Mr Brown go back
out there yes sir
William
it's not a plea called 12 Angry Men
directed by Mr Leroy Washington
and I ran off the next day hey alfalfao
they dog me out
they talked about me so bad the next
time another event came up Mr Washington
Mr Brown you were up I said no Mr
Washington everybody says no not him I
said they're right Mr Washington not me
he said Mr Brown you were up
yes sir
and I went out and pretty soon when
people laughed at me it didn't bother me
they would throw paper and I can catch
it without losing my concentration
and then one day
I came out
and a hush went across the audience
because it must have been something
about me that indicated
that I'd come to myself
and Mr Washington had been practicing
with me to give a presentation
and I looked at the audience and I said
I choose not to be a common man it's my
right to be uncommon if I can I seek
opportunity not security I do not wish
to be a kept citizen humbled and dull by
having the state look after me I want to
take the calculated risk to dream and to
build to fail and to succeed I refuse to
live from hand to mouth I prefer the
challenges of life to the guaranteed
existence the Thriller fulfillment to
the stale calm of Utopia I will never
cower before any Master nor been to any
threat it's my Heritage to stand direct
proud and unafraid to face the world
boldly and say this I have done girl
stood up saying that's my boyfriend
I like me some less brown baby
but I didn't start off like that
you have something special
you have talents and abilities in you
that you don't even know so how do we
begin to create wealth let me give you
some some ideas number one write this
down knowledge
what knowledge that you have in this
economy
part of what we need
that people are willing to pay you for
that
next is Talent what talent
Dion's talents playing football I didn't
have that as a talent
my talent is talking to me is it my
definition of success is doing what you
love to do and find somebody to pay you
to do it
so I find people to pay me to talk I
talk I bought a game to this to this
country called beard whisk that I
invented and as I talk I shoot pool I
signify I make you tear up your cards
break your cue stick because I talk a
lot of trash I'll throw you off you've
never been to Boston I'll take you there
so I learned how to signify and talk
trash all right and so I make a living
talking trash to a T I make more than
one hour than ninety percent of the
American public earned working for a
whole year doing what I love to do that
I've developed my talent you want to
master your talent find out what it is
that you love to do I love to talk
scripture is another key that says to us
that what we need to do to begin to
develop ourselves Luke 12 34 where your
treasure is there will your heart be
also so what do you love to do
and then explore ways in which you can
earn a living doing that cooking writing
painting working with numbers working
with people
the other thing is not only must you
have knowledge Talent some skill
but the other thing that's important
faith
to act on whatever your dream is
see if you don't believe in yourself how
many people you know that have a lot of
talent a lot of abilities but they don't
believe in themselves raise your hands
see that faith is very important
so the faith to act on those dreams
those desires here's scripture that I
that I like very much Proverbs 16 16th
chapter third verse commit thy works
unto the Lord and thy thoughts shall be
established
commit means to carry into action
deliberately commit means to make it
happen no matter what
commitment the difference between next
time you have bacon eggs the chicken was
involved the pig was committed
he had to give it all up that's going to
take a minute to sink in it's not all
right
see when you make a commitment I'm going
to become wealthy when you make it
important
when you decide I'm going to do it no
matter what
life changes for you see most people
don't keep their commitments to their
commitments that's why they lead lives
of poverty lives of misery lives of
unhappiness
Socrates said the uncommitted life isn't
worth living
it's a part of what you must do whatever
commitment whatever Covenant you make
with God while you're here to go back to
be a better father to go back to make a
difference in the community to go back
to change your life to decide not to
ever to use drugs or alcohol again to
decide to bet that you're going to begin
to recreate yourself that you're going
to be reborn to a new State of
Consciousness whatever commitment that
you make keep your commitment to your
commitment
no matter what if it's hard then do it
hard
or keep your commitment to your
commitment because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to see my one-on-one interview
with Les Brown check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you're marching toward purpose
meaning and impact whatever Vision that
you hold for yourself see it accomplish
and understand this